is there advice you can give to young
people today
besides reading russian literature at a
young age
um about how to find their way in life
how to find success in career or just
life in general
uh
i i just
my own
belief it may not be very
deep but i believe it i think you should
follow your dreams
and you should have dreams and follow
your dreams if you can to the extent
that you can
and
we spend a lot of our time doing
something with ourselves in my case
physics in your case i don't know
whatever it is machine learning and this
uh
we should yeah i should have fun
what was wait wait dream follow your
dreams what uh what dream did you have
because the
well well originally i was that because
you didn't follow your dream well that's
the thing i changed along the way i was
gonna be okay but i changed what
happened that was what happened
oh i read i decided to
take the most serious literature course
in my high school which was a mistake
i'd probably be a second-rate writer now
and uh could be a noble prize-winning
writer and uh
the um
the book that we read
even though i had read russian novels
i was 15 i think uh cured me
from being a novelist destroyed your
dream yes cured you okay what was the
book moby dick okay
so why moby dick yeah why so i i've read
it since
and it's a it's a great novel maybe it's
as good as the russian i've never made
it through i i thought it was too boring
it's too long okay your words are gonna
mesh with what i say excellent and you
may have the same problem at uh uh older
that's why i'm not a writer
it may be
so the problem is moby dick is
what i remember was is there was a
chapter that was maybe a hundred pages
long
all describing this why there was ahab
and the white whale and it was the
battle between ahab with his wooden peg
leg and the white whale
and there was a chapter that was 100
pages long in my memory i don't know how
long it really was
that described in detail the great white
whale and what he was doing and what his
fins were like and this and that and it
was so incredibly boring the word you
used
that i thought if this is great
literature
screw it
fascinating okay
now why did i have a problem i know now
in reflection because i i still read a
lot and i i read that
novel
you know after
i was
30 or 40 years old
and the problem was simple i i diagnosed
what the problem was i that
novel in contrast to
the russian novels which are very
realistic and
you know point of view
is one huge metaphor
oh yeah at 15 years old i probably
didn't know the word and i certainly
didn't know the meaning of a metaphor
yeah like why do i care about a fish why
are you telling me all about this yeah
exactly it's one big metaphor so reading
it later as a metaphor i could really
enjoy it
but the teacher gave me the wrong book
or maybe it was the right book because i
went into physics and so
but it was it was truly i think i may
oversimplify but it was really that i
was too young to read that book because
not too young to read the russian novels
interestingly but too young to read that
because i i probably didn't even know
the word and i certainly didn't
understand it as a metaphor
well in terms of fish i recommend people
read old man in the sea much shorter
much better still metaphor though so but
you can read it just as a story about a
guy
catching a fish and it's still fun to
read
uh
i had the same experience
as you not with moby dick but later in
college i took a course on james joyce i
don't understand why
i was majoring in computer science i
took a course on james joyce
and i was kept being told that he is
widely considered by many considered to
be the greatest
literary
writer of the 20th century
and i kept reading like i think so his
short stories the dead i think it's
called was very good
well not very good but pretty good and
then you listen to this is very good it
is very good i mean the dead the final
story is still rings with me today but
then ulysses was
i i i got through ulysses with the help
of some cliff notes and so on but
uh and so i did ulysses and then
finnegan's wake the moment i started
finning his wake
i said this this is stupid
this is that's when i went full into
like
um i don't know that's why i went full
kafka
bukowski like people who just talk about
the darkness of the human condition in
the fewest words possible
and without any of the
music of language
so it was a turning point
as well i i wonder i wonder when is the
right time to do the
to appreciate the beauty of language
like even shakespeare i was very much
off put by shakespeare in high school
and only later i started to appreciate
it's its value in the same way
let me ask you a ridiculous question
okay
um
i mean because you've read russian
literature let me ask this one last
question uh
i might be lying there might be a couple
more but what do you think is the
meaning of this whole thing
you